Pour yourself a parsley soda because Season
2 of A Series of Unfortunate Events is an
entertainingly dark ride that's positively
jam-packed with easter eggs!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm going to run through some very
cool things you might have missed in the new
series including references, cameos, and connections
to TV shows, movies, and the original books.
Obviously, spoilers ahead if you're not up-to-date
with Season 2.
At the start of the first episode, Mr Poe
mentions how he simply can't put down a book
called The Pony Party, which, if you look
at the jacket, seems to be the first in a
series of cheerful stories about 'the Luckiest
Kids in the World!'
written by Loney M Setnick.
However, in reality, there is no Pony Party
book, it's just a reversible cover for hardback
editions of Lemony Snicket: The Unauthorized
Autobiography, and Pony Party author Loney
M Setnick is an anagram of Lemony Snicket.
If you've read the original books, you'll
know that Olivia Caliban is a rather different
character in the TV series.
In the novels, she only appears in the 9th
book, The Carnivorous Carnival, where she's
known as the fortune-teller Madame Lulu and
she turns out to be the person who's been
giving Count Olaf information on where he
can find the Baudelaire orphans each time
they escape from him.
And she's the one who reveals to Olaf that
Beverley, Elliot, and Chabo are actually Violet,
Klaus, and Sunny!
However, in the TV show, Olivia Caliban pops
up at the start of Season 2 in The Austere
Academy episodes, where she's a librarian
who later joins up with Jacques Snicket to
try and help the Baudelaires, and later again
she takes on the alias of fortune-teller Madame
Lulu, which is a rotating position for any
VFD agent staying at the Carnival.
By the way, the Caligari Carnival and Madame
Lulu's Caligari Cabinet get their names from
a silent horror movie called The Cabinet of
Dr Caligari.
As Mr Poe drives the Baudelaires to their
next guardians in the Village of Fowl Devotees,
he talks to them about Count Omar, which you
might think was just a slip of the tongue.
"Thanks to the constant coverage in my wife's
newspaper, I'm sure Count Omar will be captured
in no time at all."
"Olaf."
"Yes, I meant to say Omar."
"Besides ..."
However, in the 7th book, The Vile Village,
the Daily Punctilio newspaper gets Count Olaf's
name wrong, calling him Count Omar, which
leads the people living in the Village of
Fowl Devotees to repeatedly refer to Count
Olaf as Count Omar, much to the frustration
of the Baudelaires.
Although the VFD villagers in the TV series
don't do this, Mr Poe does refer to Count
Omar a couple of times in Part One and Two
of The Vile Village.
"But you know that Count Omar was far from
innocent."
"Count Olaf."
"Yes, see?
Even the name gives the shivers."
"That bushy eyebrow and tattoo of that eye
on his ankle."
And the Daily Punctilio also gets Olaf's name
wrong in several articles.
In Part 2 of The Ersatz Elevator, there's
a clever call-back when, to gain access to
the "In Auction", Jacquelyn recycles the trick
that Count Olaf played on her in the first
season by using the fake name he made up to
get an appointment with Mr Poe.
"I have an appointment."
"Name?"
"Haircut."
"Haircut?"
"Yes... sica Haircut is my name."
"Yessica Haircut?"
"Yes."
"Yessica."
"Larry Your-Waiter."
"Did you get past the bouncer?"
"Not yet.
He has to let me in."
"I'm on the list."
"Yessica Haircut."
When Lemony Snicket is in the tunnels, there's
a sign for DENOUEMENT, which is a nod to the
Hotel Denouement, the main location of the
12th book, The Penultimate Peril, which will
be part of Season 3.
The sign is also a reference to triplets Ernest,
Frank, and Dewey Denouement who own that hotel.
And the word 'dénouement' is a literary term
meaning the final part of a film, play, or
story that brings together strands of the
plot.
Also, when Klaus and Violet are searching
for the Snicket files at Heimlich Hospital,
there's a file labelled 'Slippery Slopes',
which is a nod to the 10th book, The Slippery
Slope, which will be adapted in the first
episodes of Season 3.
Of course, at the end of Season 2, the Baudelaires
also literally find themselves on a slippery
slope.
There's a lovely meta-moment in episode 9
when Neil Patrick Harris drops a reference
to his previous big TV show, How I Met Your
Mother, which ran for nine seasons and was
set in New York City.
"If she's so good at fortune-telling, why
does she live here instead of having her own
show in the city?"
"I tried that for nine years.
Look where it got me."
On top of that, Season 1 featured Harris's
How I Met Your Mother co-star Cobie Smulders
playing the Quagmire children's mother!
And Season 2 brings another reunion for Harris
and a former co-star when Olaf confronts Nathan
Fillion's Jacques Snicket in the Village of
Fowl Devotees.
Harris and Fillion previously worked together
in Dr Horrible's Sing-Along Blog, where Harris
played an aspiring supervillain to Fillion's
superhero Captain Hammer.
And they're not the only shows that Neil Patrick
Harris once starred in that get a hat-tip
this season.
In episode 8, when Count Olaf meets Doctor
Faustus, who's actually Klaus in disguise,
Olaf tells Faustus that he looks 'terribly
young to be a doctor'.
Which is funny because as a young actor Harris's
breakthrough role was playing a teen genius
doctor in the comedy-drama, Doogie Howser,
MD, which ran from 1989 to 1993.
Oh, and by the way, the name Doctor Faustus
is a literary reference to a 16th-century
English play about a man who makes a deal
with the devil.
Esmé Squalor gets to wear some pretty memorable
outfits in the series, including one that
seems to draw inspiration from the villainous
Cruella de Vil.
And, later, when Esmé tells Madame Lulu that
she was forced to 'make [her] own dress from
a few scraps of tent', and then the camera
reveals holes cut out of a tent, it's reminiscent
of Disney's Enchanted, where Giselle made
herself a dress out of a set of curtains,
leaving an outline visible in the remaining
material.
Now, you might think that's a stretch, but
Enchanted was produced by Barry Sonnenfeld
and he's the showrunner for A Series of Unfortunate
Events.
Indeed, Barry Sonnenfeld also pops up several
times, including in a cameo as Aunt Josephine's
husband Ike Anwhistle; on a poster for 'Barry
the Pinhead' at the Caligari Carnival; and
he also provides the voice of Mr Tamerlane
during Mr Poe's phone conversation about The
Pony Party.
"Poe, are you there?"
"Focus, Poe."
"What about the Baudelaires?"
"Ah, yes, the Baudelaires."
"Put down the book."
"I'll put this down."
And speaking of cameos, Neil Patrick Harris's
real-life husband, David Burtka, plays a rather
vocal audience member during the Carnivorous
Carnival episodes and they're joined in the
season finale by their actual children Harper
and Gideon.
The makers of A Series of Unfortunate Events
are obviously big fans of director Stanley
Kubrick's The Shining because they already
included a nod to the famous horror movie
in Season 1.
"Here's Shammy!"
And they pay tribute to it again, not once
but twice in Season 2!
In Part One of the Hostile Hospital, administrator
Babs is wandering the hospital's corridors
in the dark when she's frightened by the two
identically-dressed White-Faced Women who
suddenly appear ahead of her.
"Hello, Babs, come and play with us."
This scene is a clear hat-tip to the Grady
sisters in The Shining, who appear to young
Danny asking him to come and play with them
as he's tricycling along the hotel's corridors.
In the second part of the Baudelaire's story
at Heimlich Hospital, the Henchperson of Indeterminate
Gender smashes down the door to a room where
Violet, Klaus and Sunny are hiding.
"Here I am, Nurse Lucafont."
Which is a parody of Jack Nicholson's famous
line, 'Here's Johnny'.
Now, what were your favourite easter eggs
and moments in the show?
And what are you most looking forward to in
season 3?
I can't wait to read your comments below!
You can also tweet me @Jan_Gilbert or @FlicksCity.
Remember to like, subscribe, and turn on your
notifications, if you enjoyed this video.
And you can click here for more videos you'll
like, including my Season 1 Unfortunate Events
easter eggs!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!